this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] it's Monday the 26th of
September the joint is brought to you by
freeze pipe listen it's getting cold out
there celebrate before by blowing a big
icy cloud in the [__] woods with
freeze pipe just freeze it pack it and
[__] rip it the Hot Smoke
passes through the Frozen part cooling
down the smoke and you inhale let me
tell you something they just sent me the
the new bongs for 2023 oh my [__] god
this bubbler is [__] tremendous now
freeze pipe is even better they've
updated their bungs so they have six
independent reading freezing coil for
even better airflow and much easier
cleaning experience your Uncle Joe is
taking care of your [__] it's
Monday go to thefreeze pipe.com press
and call Joey and save 10 off your first
[__] order get yourself a new
bong for yourself for Thanksgiving for
the pilgrims get a bang a pipe or a
bubbler that's thefreeze pipe.com
pressing code Joey and save ten percent
though you understand me the joint is
also brought to you by
expressvpn listen go on that dark web
and you get some [__] goodies but you
need expressvpn Uncle Joey only
recommends brands that I [__] believe
in and when I say expressvpn is the best
you know it's the [__] truth
first off expressvpn doesn't log in your
activity online lots of pre-vpns make
money by selling your data to
advertisers not expressvpn they're
[__] tremendous their servers are
incapable of storing any data at all
expressvpn is always blasting fast and
lets me stream videos and HD quality you
don't need any technical skills just get
set up just fire up the app tap one
button to connect Bim bamboo boom there
you are [__] looking beautiful that's
why CNET Business Insider and The Verge
all rate
expressvpn the number one VPN in the
world what the [__] are you waiting for
okay I use VPN when I'm in the hotel
room I love expressvpn because it gives
you peace of mind knowing that your data
is secure so protect yourself with the
VPN that I use and Trust use Uncle
Joey's link ready
expressvpn.com show it and when you put
in Joey you're going to get an extra
three month free on your one year
package it's Monday I'm swinging out
[__] gifts like I'm swinging out
[__] dick happy rosh hashan other
[__] that's expressvpn.com
Joey visit expressvpn.com to learn more
and what else it's [__] Monday
[__] get the Chinese guy in the
order and get some spare ribs we're
talking Monday Night Football we're
talking touchdowns big plays bigger wins
we're talking about the Giants
versus the Cowboys tonight
new customers bet five dollars on any
team I'll tell you what is important
because you get two bills and three bets
and it starts your bankroll to start
betting 20 a night for to see when Aaron
judge hits a home run and that's not
enough everybody can boost their
winnings with DraftKings stepped up same
game parlays and their [__]
prop bets are the best in the business
with bigger payouts than ever to make
things even sweeter you can throw down
same game parlays once a day but you
start with you download draftkingsport
forget right now use promo code Joey to
get 203 bets if your team wins when you
place a five dollar bet on any football
team that's coach Joey only at
DraftKings Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the NFL minimum age
and eligibility restrictions apply see
show notes for details now do me a favor
download the draftkingsport book app
order fantasy app and let's start making
some money pressing code Joey let's do
this Mike
[Music]
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
Joy
[Music]
foreign
all right all right all right you bad
[__] where the [__] you been
it's Monday the 26th of the month we
already killed this [__] this
thing is down that's it this is your
last week to [__] shine guys so uh
make a [__] work you know what I'm
saying it was a great week but now we're
on to another one I got two more weeks
till the [__] next show I already
been writing a few things how funny it
is I have no [__] idea but you never
know till you try it uh had a great
[__] weekend my daughter's softball
team is 6-0 listen they know they're
like the Cincinnati Reds man they
they walked they [__] hit singles and
every great once in a while they hit a
home run but let me tell you something
their [__] defense is uh just it's
great to watch it's great to see these
girls two years ago and to see them now
this is why I tell people to come don't
[__] quit dick don't quit dick if you
like it and it's working for you and
it's not killing you stick with it
because oh my God it's like they're
they're like a machine and watching it
makes me [__] happy because when I
was young I didn't see that [__] I never
saw that type of like growth in anything
you know you smoke pot you played
football you play I don't know so it
didn't make you really want to stick
with something you thought when you did
something the first or two times you're
like I'm not good at this I'm not gonna
stick with it but if you haven't listen
it's like me with cars
I don't have an interest to get [__]
under a car I don't I really don't I I'm
just bad at it did I try it for years I
changed spark plugs I did my own [__]
oil do you know for a while I changed my
own oil when I lived in Boulder for some
reason or another it wasn't even to save
the 10 bucks or whatever it was just to
do it
you know because it was just to do it
because I'm sick and tired of not being
able to do dick so I would just [__]
do it you know and then it was an Acura
it was a small car I could pull it up to
a thing uh and just unscrew a thing and
put the bucket under there I changed the
air filter on my own I did all stupid
[__] like that but when it came to
fixing carburetors and [__] axles and
[__] you got the wrong guy you know so I
knew I didn't have the aptitude for it
Jiu Jitsu I don't have the aptitude for
it at all whatsoever just like car
mechanics but I like it I'm sweating I'm
pulling I'm getting [__] tackled you
know every once in a while it feels kind
of good to get beat up guys it really
does just to remind you you're a [__]
you know when you go up against a skinny
guy that weighs a buck and a half and
he's throwing you around like a rag doll
and you're like yeah I gotta start
eating [__] Kellogg's again or some
[__] because this [__] just is not
[__] working but yesterday we had a
a very [__] nice experience at the
softball field we'll have to touch it on
it and change the names
so uh nobody will be [__] insulted by
this he's a dear friend of mine I love
these guys listen I love all the parents
I hang out with here I I gotta be honest
with you if you would have told me 10
years ago when I'm at The Comedy Store
one night talking to guys that come here
for a second you're not going to be
talking to these guys forever in about
10 years you're going to be hanging out
with parents watching stupid softball
games and stuff like that what do you
think about that I go
you know what as a Swami it's not going
to work out for you because you can't
[__] read the future but I gotta tell
you something man my happiest moments
all week
have been in this fall ball [__] on
Saturdays it's [__] beautiful out we
get sandwiches we get [__] you know
iced tea with lemon in it and [__] and
he just sit there you read a few Edibles
you sit there that double-headed so you
enjoy the [__] game the sun's on you
you're talking to parents you're talking
to moms they're telling you about their
jobs and their lives guys I gotta tell
you something it's pretty interesting I
remember the first time Jimmy Florentine
told me he said you're gonna have a good
time talking to the parents at the games
I'm like I guess Jimmy doesn't know me
too much but boy I have a great time and
you know you build relationships you go
over to the house the girls do things
together it's [__] magical
so there's this couple that all my
friends you know they [__] dabble all
the parents they either do or they don't
or they drink [__] martinis like
would I be on a Monday morning get that
[__] dick card get this party started
tons of minerals vitamins everything you
[__] eyeballs start to Blink
so we're sitting there yesterday
game starts at [__] nine o'clock it's
a double headed we're gonna be there
until about two 1 30. let's make the
best of it you know every three Innings
I get up I walk around the Little League
field
I go pick a piss by the car even though
there's a bathroom I just still love
pissing by the car if I get away with it
right on on the weeds or whatever the
[__] I go I know this they'll get you on
the pedophile Patrol and then uh but I
bring a bottle with me I bring a
hospital by I like two Hospital bottles
I put in both cars my wife's and mine in
case I gotta make a [__] Quick Trip
into the woods like [__] uh Bella
Lugosi so
I'm uh at this game and [__]
I'm sitting talking to them and I take
out these Edibles whenever I order from
Stoner Club
they you know you order Edibles from
Stoner club or wheat and they always
send you little gifts they send you a
couple joints they know I like the
edible so they sent me all these mic
likes
the [__] 600 milligram in a bag like
six [__] thing listen I just eat the
whole bag in fact I got so high the
other night it was 11 30 at night and I
couldn't find nothing sweet to eat so I
just ate a bag of Mike and ice
already I was [__] up I used to do
this all the time in L.A when Anthony
Dolores was around she'd have the
pretzels and all that [__] I'd get high
go home look for munchies and also I'd
eat 500 milligrams more pretzels because
each Pretzel was 15 milligrams nobody
remembers Anthony Dollars [__] so she
had the [__] peanuts you would just
have him one time I gave a pretzels to a
stewardess without even [__] thinking
and I got off the plane I'm like that
[__] is gonna be [__] up because you
couldn't tell so so I had the I had the
uh Mike and Ike's the other night I woke
up I couldn't understand my my [__]
eyes were Wide Shut when I woke up it
was like I have pink eye the next
morning you ever have pink eye you wake
up you have like a [__] crust and
[__] so I get up man I'm talking to
these guys this couple and I go it's 11
30. you know it's that time so this bag
had
I think it was 250 milligrams but they
were in 25s
it was like grapes hours or whatever but
on the top of the back it's an extremely
potent
so the gentleman I was with had just
said to me hey I ate one of your 15
milligrams last week from True dose the
ones from Stoner Club
because this [__] are pretty
good I go you had a little cake goes
yeah no problem so once you do 15 what
what what's the difference with 25
milligrams wow 10 milligrams right so I
give one to his wife I give one to him
and I eat the rest you know me I'm a
[__] carbon right so I put down 200
milligrams and it didn't do dick it got
me a little for a little while when I
had to take a pee one time so I'm
sitting there with them and we're
talking and all of a sudden we're going
to the giggle phase
we're giggling
my wife's looking at herself the other
moms are looking at this like we're
[__] three retards and next thing you
know I'm looking at my buddy here
and I could see he's getting a little
sweat around his nose right I'm like wow
it's hot out but I'm not sweating in
fact it was [__] cold as [__]
yesterday
so I uh
keep checking on them you know
and I noticed that he stops cheering for
his daughter and that's a sign right
there because you know we all cheer for
our kids and [__] and their kids and he
stopped cheering for his daughter and
that's what I got concerned I started
looking at them they had sunglasses on
so I couldn't see he was just sitting
there looking like Jim Jones and Guyana
when he made those poor [__] people
drink the [__] Kool-Aid and [__] he
was just sitting like that so I kept
asking me okay and he's like yeah I got
this and then finally I could just see
his mouth dried up you know I sent I
asked him if he wanted water or Coke he
went yes and my wife brought the water
or the coke he just pointed at the coke
that's when they Point you're done I
mean he didn't pull an Owen Benjamin on
me but he went deep you know uh I gave
him some [__] water you know we kept
giving him water and love you know now I
was fine and his wife was fine so I knew
it was something with the edibles but
you know sometimes you get up in the
morning you get a little gung-ho he had
had a little something in his stomach
and he caught [__] THC poisoning
which listen you [__] have
known me for a long time and uh I love
my Edibles you guys all always saw me
just eating like 2 000 milligrams with
Lee or eating a thousand stars or
whatever that's all fine and dandy but
it took work to get there and these are
the stories you never [__] hear about
you never hear about those stories when
we [__] pass out or when my friend
had to call the ambulance on the 101
because he was driving he thought he was
having a heart attack there's a thousand
listen on your quest to the edible
Journey you're gonna have a couple
accidents as we call them okay you're
gonna have some [__] accidents and
while I was talking to him last night
and then when I you know towards the end
of the game the game ended and I sat
there with him for a little while you
know he didn't you know we didn't want
to mingle with the other parents and
[__] not yet they're nice white people
then they left and uh I walked into his
car he got a little sick which was good
the alcohol the THC poisoned
[__] came out of him and then when
you're in that situation always remember
CBD that's why you always got to carry
cbd-line detention I don't care if you
go to CBD line by the cheapest tincture
they have
that picture will set you [__]
straight when you're high when you're
just getting that a little bit too much
your heart's beating you don't know
what's really going on going on you
think the Martians are surrounding you
stop take a breath call for Grandma
grandma get the CBD I'm going deep into
the murky Waters and just put it under
your [__] tongue and you'll be forgot
you'll be fine trust me what I'm telling
you and sure enough my wife brought him
some CBD and within two hours he was
fine I spoke to him this morning and it
all worked out I was a little scared
that I wasn't feeling too good about
myself when it happened
[Music]
but you know what man uh
if it would have just been him and I I
would have been more upset but
since his wife took it and nothing
happened to her
we'll find that it was just uh
THC [__] overload
there was a period when we were eating
that banana bread
the guys I went through hell and back
hell and back hell and back with that
banana bread what listen there's no
cameras around when you're [__] up
like I wish I would have taped myself in
one of those positions
you know the the one that sticks out of
my [__] mind like I was telling my
wife yes I go Terry you know you
sometimes you just have bad days and
good days with those edibles
When you pray for the best and you put
an edible in your mouth if it's over
your reins like let's say you're eating
10 to go to Grandma's house on Sundays
they eat spaghetti and on this day you
decide to eat 25 you know just note that
[__] could turn for you real quick start
breathing a little bit I mean I've seen
it I've seen it it's funny for a few
minutes and then you think about that
person how you felt when you were there
and that's all I could think about when
I was looking at them yesterday
there was one day when we had no idea
what the banana bread was in it I mean
you you took your chances with that
thing I saw Yoshi go down I saw a bunch
of [__] go down on that banana
bread but I never thought I'd go down
was I [__] wrong
and one day I had a meeting and I went
there and gave me a slice and I didn't
want it to [__] melt
told you this [__] story and on the
way home I was out of it in the car and
I'm driving on Chandler
Chandler in La is the street in the
valley and it's [__] wide open all
the time everybody's driving on
the other [__] main streets Ventura
and [__] Channel I got on channel for a
[__] reason
because nobody would see me I mean I was
driving with no t-shirt on
tits are sweating
I'm no color I remember the people
pulled up to me in the car and just
looked at me I mean when do you pull up
to a car and the person driving doesn't
have a [__] shirt on and it's like
May or something it wasn't even that hot
I had a suit on I'd take that
[__] off and I'll never forget
at that light I turned around and there
was a huge bottle a container of water
like the big ones not the 12 ounce ones
or the 16 but it was like 24 that I had
just bought one day or somebody gave it
to me and I took two sips of and threw
in the back seat that [__] car was
old that water was old and mummified but
I didn't give a [__] how bad I was
feeling I had to take that water and
down it and it was kind of warm people
say that when you drink warm water your
titties grow it raises the estrogen and
if you're a man or whatever I don't know
what the rumor is but all I know is by
the time I got home I was [__] out of
it I mean out of it I had to sit on a
[__] chair and I put the air on the
air conditioner we didn't have central
air in that house the [__] air
conditioning was right here
and it's blowing on me and I'm like I'm
gonna [__] die and all of a sudden my
cat jumped on me
once the cat jumped on me I'm like and I
love this cat you know me I don't you
can't kick an animal or push it you know
you could tell him please get off me but
I felt so bad because she he wanted to
just be with me his face was right there
while I had the [__] anxiety and the
next thing you know he's sticking his
claws into me you know when they do that
with their claws and [__] I'm like
[__] I wanted to punch him and
when I [__] realized what I was
thinking I go the anxiety's gone
and that's how I got that was a four
[__] hour death ride that day you
know we we tell the story a little
faster than what had happened we don't
talk about parking and getting out and
holding on to the car for four minutes
because you thought the street was gonna
[__] turn on you you have no [__]
idea so I know how he felt yesterday
so I felt shitty you know and I told him
I said just go home you know take the
CBD take a nap balance your body sweat
it out tomorrow morning and this morning
he hit me up and he goes I know what I'm
resting he gave me the line from
Goodfellas so
I feel a lot better now nobody thought
I'd dosed them or you know because they
always get that [__] call from people
that I went to a I'm sick and tired
listen guys I'm telling you this I love
you [__] and I know there's a
lot of creepy [__] people out there
if you go out to drink to a bar please
watch your [__] drink and keep your
eyes on it I tell you why every [__]
weekend I hear I'm somewhere and
somebody says oh my sister went to a
club and
if somebody does to drink and nothing
happened but listen I hear it all the
[__] time and it's getting old guys
how come nobody doses guys [__]
drinks
you're not eating and you're [__] not
big enough to handle a [__] Long
Island Iced Tea stop blaming it I've got
dose no you didn't nobody wants to
[__] dose you you just [__] over
drink and it's always a [__] dose so
everybody that's with you has to feel
bad cover your [__] drinks God damn
it every week my sister went out and
took like somebody just told me this
couple days ago at the gym that somebody
went to like a restaurant that I liked
around town and they said they got dosed
on a Wednesday night hello
Jesus Christ when is this [__] going to
end with everything and men don't ever
get dosed I never get a call from
[__] uh Theo Vaughn you're not gonna
believe what happened man I got ghosts
last night I went to about nobody
[__] stop it stop it [__]
everybody's getting dosed all of a
sudden I didn't dose nobody you know me
though I only used to dose that one girl
we used to dose each other but besides
that I've never really dosed anybody
except Lee but he knew he was getting
those so and no but I didn't I don't
yeah I don't stop but I told them what
they were eating it's not like you put
in their [__] drink and then they
don't [__] know it's an interesting
week this week because I was thinking a
lot about Mike this week
and I was thinking about
how you never really prepared to get
married like you can have all this [__]
cooking for you you know mice get
married this weekend uh I've known Mike
for a few years you know I normally
didn't have kids also he's got one kid
also he [__] knocked her up again and
it's like what the [__] happened you
know
but you know my man guys
marriage either brings the best out of
you
or marriage will [__] you up you know
it's a 50 50 thoughts on this and we all
know this we all know
somebody who's gotten separated or
divorced or you know and I gotta tell
you something marriage is a lot of hard
work
and marriage is you got to eat [__] from
time to time
and we don't like eating [__]
you know when I first got married when I
was whatever [__] age I was uh
I was 26 when I got married you know and
I think I was 25 when I got thrown in
prison
feet
and I was not ready
for both events in my life I was ready
to smoke Coke and the Rob and have a
good time but I wasn't ready
I didn't know this you know and and I
look at my life now
and you know I go to Jujitsu I can do a
couple things and most of the people I
hang with the 10 years younger than me
you know
some of them are married and some of
them are single I mean I have friends
like my buddy Sean coach Sean at Hollis
he's 20 [__] eight years old I love
this [__] kid
we talk you know a couple times a week
he teaches me two days a week when I go
to the court class
with tight I look at kids like that you
know he's a young man he's not a kid
but
see when how young guys treat me and I
love I listen I love you no matter how
old you are it doesn't make a difference
to me
but they'll call me to do things and it
[__] flatters me to no end you know
and it kills me to say no to them
because if this was 12 years ago if you
guys know anything about me I'd be more
[__] social
but people sometimes call me and they'll
go hey man what are you doing right now
and I'm like I'm sitting here with the
girls I'm like we just want to let you
know that we're having lunch somewhere
or we're having dinner somewhere and
that warms my [__] heart
but it's very rough to tell your wife
and your daughter Hey listen there's
three Innings left in the game
I gotta go I'm gonna go eat with my
friends and I'll see you guys later
very rough to do that as a single man
you think we could do that all day and I
appreciate
I appreciate it and I love when I have a
dear friend that says that my wife has
my balls you know what I'm saying she's
like I don't see you no more because
your wife has your balls I have like
three friends that say that to me now
anybody who knows me knows I run rampant
from Monday to Friday that's the house
rule I run [__] rampant while she's
in school
from 8 10 to [__] 3 10 until she gets
off that bus guys I could do whatever
the [__] I want
okay
Saturday days if she doesn't have a
softball game I can do whatever the [__]
I want
Sundays you know I do a podcast two
times a week I go to one spot a week I
try to [__] do you know I'm not going
I went last week to jiu jitsu one time
but to watch the black belt class I had
to watch it first before I show up this
week and the next four week goals to
just go to one class a [__] night
especially if I [__] get this movie
so you just can't you know sometimes
they'll call them and go listen after
class we're all gonna go get barbecue or
something guys
you know me I'm a fat [__] at the Jiu
Jitsu somebody gives you [__] brisket
are you [__] kidding me
I do that all day long but I can't
because the girls are waiting for me to
go eat lunch and I go to a party or
whatever
and it's listen I still
till this day
wish I [__] could just grab them one
last time and tell them how much I love
him and I miss them but I wish I could
tell Ralphie I could apologize to
Ralphie
because if there was anybody I used to
get angry over this and I'm telling you
guys the truth when Ralphie would call
me and say hey man I'm gonna pick you up
at eight o'clock I just landed it's two
o'clock I'll be there at 8 30. I go what
the [__] what do you mean ain't 8 30 he
go I gotta stop at the house and see my
kids and see my wife and eat something
and God knows what's going to happen but
I should be out of the house by 8 30. he
would pick me up at 9 9 30 but I'd be
furious deep down inside I'd go
wait a second you make all this [__]
money
and you still got to do this [__] I did
not understand guys even and this had to
be uh
you know
10 12 13 years ago
I was that naive that I would be like
come on Ralphie
just I didn't understand I didn't
understand
I had no idea I still remember being at
a burger place with my wife she's
seven months pregnant and I'm telling
her how
we're gonna have this kid
but I'm not really going to be involved
with this this isn't my world
I'm not good at this [__] you know so
I'll just go out and work as much as I
can and give you money and she was like
then we should just get a divorce right
now because that's not gonna work for me
I'm going to forget that day
and she just flipped the [__] table
on me she's like you got to be involved
a little bit and then I agreed with her
and you know but then you know what
happens
the child is born
and as Mike knows
for the first few weeks of having a kid
you're like Jesus Christ
there's some pain in the ass the first
two months there's not a man that you'll
talk to ladies if you're watching this
I'm sorry to blow your bubble
but for the first month six weeks after
we have a kid
when we go to work we're like man give
me overtime
give me all the overtime you got I don't
want to be around that [__] ugly kid
and my wife complaining and getting up
in the middle all night because you know
the kid ain't looking at you they just
looking up and [__] you don't [__]
know that your kid you know you don't
know what the [__] is going on here you
know
but then you look at this child one day
and you pick them up and you play with
his little fingers and his feet and
you're like okay I'm all in and then
they start coming to you
and what are you gonna [__] do we're
gonna be our dads I gotta go you know
now you gotta [__] you gotta [__]
talk to them and then pick them up and
you know I look at pictures sometimes at
her and I just watching videos in the
morning just sitting there when she was
three two four you know that's our
little [__] thing and now it grew
into us watching a little TV at night
and talking about what we were we
watching the other day well then I will
watch you know they were watching The
Godfather was on Showtime we had to kill
a half hour and there was the part when
Michael tells me he wants to shoot
salazzo and McCluskey and [__] she's
like [__] loving it when he was
shooting a gun in the basement you know
it grew into that but that that's not
what I'm talking about
what I'm talking about is how
there's young guys and there's a guy I
loved that he's about 40 something
you know he's a good looking dude he
slings dick like a [__]
and he's my friend I I think I met him
down here it's like he's an old friend
from North Bergen or anything I met him
down here I like the hell out of this
dude but this dude caused me to do [__]
and I feel so guilty because deep down
inside I want to go to this places with
him like he invited me to 516 last week
was 6 18 whatever the restaurant and
Freehold that's tough to get into and I
had softball practice
the other side but here's the thing when
I'm at that softball practice
there's no other place I'd rather be
but now here I am sitting there I'm not
smoking dope it's like I'm drinking beer
it's like I got a [__] ghetto blaster
behind me listen to music I'm fishing
you ever go fishing you grow your thing
in
you sit there and then sometimes
somebody gives you a joint sometimes
somebody passes you some Blackberry
brandy or whatever the [__] it is you
know
it's just really uh I want people to
understand it's a big move when you get
married anything in life it's like that
line from The Sopranos
when Paulie tells uh whatever listen you
got to pay me six thousand a month or
six thousand a week
that could be a lot
well that could be a little that's up to
you guys
that could be a lot of though or that
could be a [__] little that's a
strong statement right there but it just
I enjoy what I'm doing now that I
enjoyed this 15 years ago not in a
million years
while she was pregnant I was ready to
pull my hair out but now
this has taken my manhood to a different
level when you're married listen guys I
says as much as your friends tell you
[__] and everything
when you're married when you get married
it takes your manhood to a different
level whether you fail in the marriage
or it prospers or it blossoms or
whatever the [__] you want to say think
about what I'm saying here
listener you get married at 28. and
after the first six months you're like
this sucks
you know and listen I said that dog I
said it on the honey when I first got
married my first wife when I was 26
on the honeymoon I was thinking that and
the plane
we had just got married at lunch time
we're on a honeymoon plant at seven
o'clock and I'm already going
I think I made a mistake
that's not [__] good and obviously I
made a mistake and it cost me money
but I knew
at the time I didn't think I liked
fatherhood when all that went down
fatherhood and the divorce and marriage
at that time I couldn't be married to
who named the hottest chick in the
[__] world
the chick with Machine Gun Kelly if she
shuts her [__] mouth you know Jay
whatever her name is she's good looking
bro but shut the [__] up Megan and you
know she was like a millionaire whatever
like that still wouldn't have worked
because I just wasn't ready I was still
a [__] Renegade and then when I tell
you I'm ready
please don't think it was because oh I
was on them they had nothing to do with
sex or being with women I just wasn't
ready for little things I wasn't ready
to help somebody with their [__]
laundry
right or wrong we have a hard time going
to bring our own [__] laundry down
now I Gotta Throw your panties in the
laundry and look at your [__] vanilla
milk [__] bras and I have no smell
why are we washing these bras they smell
like nothing every once in a while I get
a little onion by the [__] armpit but
you know there's just a thousand things
that you gotta help him make a bed you
gotta help them vacuum
when I built that [__] and then you got
guys that are making money that tell
them I'm taking care of everything those
[__] are never gonna [__]
bend over and do anything
trust me I'm telling you I I see what
goes on in relationships listen I'm not
Johnny [__] the best around the house
but I try to help her a little bit I
take the garbage out I [__] you know
go get groceries from time to time I
take Mercy to all his softball games I'm
at all the practices I'm with all the
kickboxing events you know that takes a
lot of [__] time
could I do this at 28
I could lie to you
I could lie to you and tell you oh I
could have done this [__] I couldn't
have done this in [__] 28 years old
so I want to congratulate Mike on his
wedding and if any of you guys are
thinking about it
or whatever I just want you to be
prepared for it I see a lot of people
especially when you're under 30 you
don't even see the transition you think
you get some point of peer pressure
somewhere and then also you're getting a
ring
and once you get the [__] ring you
open up
[__] Pandora's box of emotions and
feelings from everybody
and meanwhile you're like could I make a
[__] mistake I've been there guys
we've all been there it's okay to admit
it now to her you know tell her tonight
on the way home I gotta tell you what
Uncle Joey was saying that we're happy I
love you to death but the first month I
wanted to stab you after the wedding but
we grew into it you really do you grow
into it or it doesn't work for you first
time I got married guys it did not
[__] work for me we got
it did not at any level I I still think
about those times and time you know just
when I have a disagreement with my wife
today I just look at my first marriage
and I go okay this is I learned so much
of it but the main thing I learned about
my first marriage was about me
and what I was going to tolerate and
what I couldn't do and what you know
first thing I didn't like about my first
marriage was I married her not her
[__] family and don't get me wrong
I'm not saying this in a bad way
I love the family I love the brothers I
love the girls I shouldn't even bring
this up but
I was surrounded with them and they were
great to me at that time the
the father was great the whole thing
what I'm trying to say is if you live in
Philadelphia
move your plan your in-laws to Hershey
Park you know what I'm saying they're
two hours away
two hours is perfect for your in-laws
you know and if you may you understand
and again like look at my in-laws today
I [__] love my in-laws last Sunday I
spoke to every girl in the family my
sister-in-law my wife's brother's side
my sister-in-law my sister's side my
wife's side her daughter and my
mother-in-law I'm tight with them I like
them we talked about fried chicken and
[__] like that because they live in the
south
foreign
but there's just a lot of things that
you might not like your first time
you know the her parents lived in
Boulder and I opted to move to Boulder
so it seemed like and there were
sweethearts I shouldn't even have said
that because that didn't even affect me
but it was kind of
ah there was parts of it you know I was
I always found myself over her house
that's what I'm trying to say that I
didn't have parents
so when you don't have parents to kill
off the balance you find yourself
over at their home for all the events
the holidays whatever
and I just wish I would have had family
out there to represent my own you know
to bring so she'd go see that Mike since
I've been to Jersey yeah we do Christmas
here we do Christmas around the corner
and one of the girls house with all the
kids but we also do the Christmas at one
of my buddy's house in Jackson he's like
my brother we go over there like meal
whatever just to take the [__]
pressure off both sides but marriage is
a beautiful thing will you be ready for
it when you're 23 I don't know
you gotta try will you be ready for it
when you're 25 I don't know
you got to try how old are you now Mike
41 Wednesday so
he's ready he's got about he's got he's
got no choice he had [__] kids you
know when I walked in here today I want
to talk to you guys about something real
quick
uh I have a lot of comedians on patreon
I have a lot of comedians who I just
listen they asked simple questions
when I was in LA and the podcast was
bigger and I was touring I would get
more emails from Comics but they were
all looking for handouts or a guest set
or for me to put them on the Rogan part
and listen you get the most outlandish
request but when the comic hits me and
says Hey listen do you have any tips for
writing or
I'm trying to get into this club and the
owner I get those type of questions and
I really enjoy those you know
and every once in a while I get the
number one question I get is how long
does it take to get rocking and rolling
you know like and when I say rock and
rolling I'm not talking about your own
[__] Network television
or you got the number three podcast in
the world I'm talking about you paying
your bills
you're making progress uh you're working
towards something every quarter you know
there's always something going on and
may not be the biggest thing but there's
always something going on
I think the
to for me to continue with this I have
to tell you my personal situation with
this one of the best careers I'm gonna
tell you something guys one of the best
careers in Hollywood
the best probably is voiceovers
there's tons of money in it
there's tons of opportunity in it
and you don't have to do a lot of
[__] [__] you get the audition from
your voice over agent
you take a room
quarter the size of this could be a
closet it could be a closet you put a
microphone in there
just the same setup we're doing here in
fact I got to do a voice this is why
we're talking about this
I have to do a voice show but tomorrow
that I've been working on since
Wednesday I'm really excited about this
boy so
I made copies you know and it's easy all
I got to do is put on my voice memo
that's it and send it by Monday at 12
o'clock and they want two different
takes so I'm gonna give them a dirty
take
and a clean tank you know as I call it
one for them
one for me the one for them is going to
be to the book
to the book no improvising nothing like
that and the one for me I already know
how I'm going to do this one is going to
be close to the book I'm just going to
give it color that's what happens when
you smoke some weed and you eat one of
those Philly mushroom [__] gummies
you start giving [__] color so
I'm looking at these voiceovers and this
is like I said this is a great [__]
career for people I'll give an example
Vincent Pastor I'm not here to spread
this [__] [__] around because
he's a great guy he's been very good to
me I don't know he did Shark Tale he got
uh and he never told me this I just
heard this
you know he got whatever he gets to
shoot a day two thousand a day three
thousand a day and you shoot maybe three
or four days
okay and you move on right you guys like
Joey that's not a lot of money well nine
thousand dollars a lot of money
especially where I come from
but his residual check was a hundred
thousand
the first residual check now that was 20
years ago you still had to go into a
studio which I don't mind going into a
spirit do a voiceover there's a One
camera on you really and whatever so
for years this is a [__] minute I
walked into L.A in 97 people were like
hey you got a great voice hey you got a
great voice how come you should do
voiceovers first [__] people to ever
contacted me in Los Angeles were
[__] sunbart the vanari 20 years ago
they were the biggest camera 25 years
ago this 25 years ago when I signed with
them they were huge I mean I got to La
January 29th
and I had signed with them like by
February 7th like they saw me at The
Improv and said we want you
and it doesn't matter they they signed
me for commercials print and anything
else but they I asked them about
voiceovers and they were like in time
and I didn't understand them like these
[__] everybody tells me I got a
great voice and blah blah blah but
nobody ever talked to me for years
you know I I took voice over classes
like intro to voice over like Tuesday
nights for 60 bucks for eight weeks I
took one of those
she taught me how to make a demo tape
you know you're going through a [__]
thing and
do the different voices that you do like
I'm a man of any voices I got one
[__] voice you know
so uh you put down tape and then you
send that out and for years
nothing
so I kind of got discouraged I didn't
know I think nothing I mean guys I can't
even remember I was thinking about this
I banged my head for like 30 minutes the
other day nothing has a voiceover tons
of commercial work I'm very happy and
then I did a movie American Gun with uh
James Coburn
foreign
we did at this bowling alley on uh
I don't know where the [__] it was oh I
was on Melrose there was this famous
bowling alley I went in there one day to
get french fries they took me there in
the afternoon I saw Janine Garofalo on
Andy Dick in there playing [__] up
and it was like eight alternative
comedian Hangout
and they did comedy there but one night
we were shooting a movie in the parking
lot I got a roll in this [__] movie
Rick Pagano was the casting director and
there was a movie with James Coburn and
[__] uh
you know my time is 11 o'clock at night
and they're like you know what we have
no trailers do you mind just sitting in
your car until you shoot we'll get you
out of here well it didn't get me out of
there and at four in the morning they
broke me for lunch I go [__] home and
I get some reef and I bring it back to
the [__] set because they're like
you're not gonna shoot till like seven
in the morning I'm like what the [__]
I don't understand movies back then it
was like 2 000 Maybe 2001.
and this is one of those stories that
I'm gonna tell you you're gonna draw
your line to us but it's the truth
because sometimes you just get [__]
blamed for conspiracy
when I got back and forth I had some
[__] wheat I smoked a joint in the
parking lot and I sat in my car at one
point I said you know what I'm kind of
thirsty so I walked into the trailer
when I had the food and James Coburn
sitting there with another dude and two
chicks and they're drinking beers I'll
never forget James Coburn had arthritis
in his hands the way he was holding his
beer cups I was just happy to be around
them I walk in
now I could tell that they just weren't
smoking dope and drinking a bit
but while I was in there getting the
water they one of the guys go hey you
want to hit this joint now James Coburn
shooting this [__] movie and the
other guy is shooting this movie you
know I was trying to be [__]
professional but somebody you know do
you want to smoke this joint I got you
sure so I take a hit of the joint right
there the [__] director auction
history with the joint in the [__]
hand I give back to the actor I leave
today how you doing you're going to be
up next okay I go to my car
they I do the same I give the gun to
James Coburn I sell it to him for 15
bucks I'm just a [__] guy in a
windbreaker I go up to him he says you
got it I got it thank you and I walk
away that was my big scene with James
Colbert three days later my agent calls
and he goes what happened on that
[__] set last night
what are you talking about nothing
happened
it was great I shot my sink it was a
director said you went home and got beer
I go I don't drink why the [__] would I
get beer and bring it to a set I go I
went home to get a [__] half a joint
that I had I was broke I go I had like a
half a joint I just wanted to do
something that I wasn't going to shoot
right away I was sitting there [__]
sober all goddamn night so
I go I get back and I go to the thing
they get a water and James cobras and
they're drinking beers and smoking dope
at 4 30 in the [__] morning I don't
know what's going on
and he goes well I'll direct the sad
that
when you walk down you look to the table
and there was coke on the table did you
see that and I go not at all I didn't
see [__]
and he goes well they said that one of
the actors was pretty hammered and they
thought that you were doing coke with
them I'm like come on Jeff
come on dog I party at night by myself
not with on a set I know I can't even do
it to get on stage I knew all this [__]
at this time
and they were like okay like a week
later I got a call from [__] whatever
and they go that acting row got cut you
have to come and do paperwork to do a
voice over [__] so they took my
[__] voice they cut me from the movie
and they just wanted to use my voice
that's the only [__] time I got a
voice so
and as creepy as that story sounds I did
not bring any cocaine on that set you
know how I know because I didn't even
have the money for cocaine that night I
had nothing and I wouldn't bring Coke to
a set if you know anything about me
so that that was it I thought my
voiceover career came to a [__] end
but guess what happens the podcast world
the podcast world just
opened it up so when I signed with the
eighth and tell me like hey man would
you consider doing voiceovers I'm like
[__] yeah
and I popped uh
big city greens
and I thought when I popped big city
greens I'm like it's over that's it
[__] stand up
[__] podcast those guys make like a half
a million dollars a year
those voiceover guys they make good
money and they're all the same quiet
they drive economical cars they don't
bother they really do they bought Pro
Carlos I was Rocky all those dudes I
know those dudes for years
those big voice over guys they're
[__] they have tremendous careers
they don't leave their house and they
some of them even have to go to the set
some of them have to go to like a
recording studio and you could do
whatever recording studio you want
remember it doesn't have to be like
their recording studio so for me I gotta
go what well tell them how far the
recording studio is three [__]
minutes up the street so but the point
being is that
it took me closer
seriously guys
25 [__] years to get a voice over in
comedy 25 years in comedy and I couldn't
get a [__] voice over was I starting
to get depressed listen
you can't always get what you want you
get what you need but I was a little
concerned like Jesus Christ I can't get
no voice overs now this is where it gets
interesting for young Comics because it
all comes together and I never want you
to get [__] discouraged about this
nobody wants to [__] talk to you when
you're just funny
what a shame
what a shame that I have to tell young
Comics this when they ask me these type
of questions that
you could be a [__] hilarious feature
Act
be right there on the cusp of the
headlining you're right on the [__]
couch for headlining
and all you need is something to push
you over the [__] car it could be a
voiceover
it could be a role in a movie it could
be any of those [__] things to you
like nobody really understands to you're
in that position your
you're on the you're on the [__]
you're on tour with the Foo Fighters
you know what I'm saying it don't get no
better than that on the touring world
and you're back he opens up Dave Grohl
uses two opening acts to [__]
open from the first year on tour with
the Foo Fighters you were the first
actor you went out there and got [__]
thrown at you people told you you sucked
you know you slept you smell feet on the
bus you didn't get paid the record label
ain't paying you this is [__] you
know your own salary
but then you got to call again from the
Foo Fighters and they want you to
support on the second island but now
you're not the first man you're the
second band
the other [__] you'd do great man
you do great and then you did so great
the stones call you
and they want you to open up for them as
the second band before us you know
shit's starting to happen for you what
pushes you over the headline like I
remember seeing Sheryl Crow
and she was there with somebody else I
don't remember who it was she was
[__] tremendous Sheryl Crow
tremendous before she went up before and
this is in Boulder
and six months later
she came back headlined in charge
whatever she was charging the ticket and
it was that [__] out the Tuesday
night music Club you know but you always
need that with comedy you need that you
need that last push and you don't know
what it is and it's and it gets you so
[__] frustrated it's a three-year
struggle to find what that is for me I
thought it was going to be analyzed that
then allies that sucked dick then you
know it was just a [__] one after the
other so you kind of get down on
yourself and you're like
but once you cross that bridge to
headline I could sit here and explain to
you how you become a headliner but it
didn't happen for me I mean I don't even
know how I started headlining but it was
the longest yard that made people at
least Rogan comes in Thursday through
Sunday you come in on Wednesday and do
headline and then you know four people
come see you because why would they pay
15 bucks for you when they could pay 30
for Rogan and see you and Rogue and so
it's very rough
but you're learning how to headline but
what my point is that
nothing is really going to happen
until you start selling tickets
I've said this before and I'll say this
again you're gonna great things are
going to happen in your career they
happen for me I saw great things
happening but I couldn't figure out how
to get people through the door but I'll
tell you every I could sit here and go
to the list how it worked for me this is
how it worked for Ari you know I saw how
it happened for Joe I did all those
shows with Joe in 98 when he was still
wrapping up news radio and I saw him
just go to a different level with Fear
Factor but it wasn't just fear fact that
he took his comedy to a different level
also and that I still remember Fourth of
July one year where you know you needed
radio to uh sell tickets everybody
always man if I could do a radio show I
could sell out
and
there was no radio it was Fourth of July
weekend and [__] Rogan sold this
[__] out and there was no
podcast back then it was his
work on social media that eliminated all
that he didn't have to do radio ever
again you know ever again he dated it as
a matter of fact but my point is don't
get discouraged guys because
you know they're not going to call you
now I get calls for voice overs now like
this week I'm laying a voice over dumb
guys this is the voiceover I wanted all
my life
how long have I been in the business 32
years I'm not the star of the show
anything like that this is just a
character in a [__] Ensemble with a
comedy Ensemble I think I'm a [__]
cougar or something like that not a
broad cougar that [__] you know not one
of those cougars but a regular crazy
cougar that's a thief
it's uh recurring that means you'll do
an episode a week for whatever 13
episodes whatever they do guys I've been
looking for that role since I moved the
[__] in L.A it took 25 [__] years
25 out of 32 years of doing comedy or
being involved with comedy how's that
one for you so
I get all these emails about you know uh
Sal and I got Nick they hold my patreon
guys they're always talking to me about
little stand-up things and I'm like
listen guys
this easy
but I also want you to understand
this was the problem this is what
happened to Lee in L.A okay you guys
will listen to Tom Segura you guys
listen to Brooke Chrysler you guys
listening to Theo Vaughn they're all
great headliners
but by you listening to them and being
involved in their life you want more for
your career and I understand but you're
not there yet it's going to take some
time and I don't ever want your feelings
to get hurt if you ever have a problem
as a young comic email me on Twitter and
say Lee what was it like being when
you're an open Miker
hang out with Open Mic because I'm sure
you want to hang out with Whitney
Cummings I'm sure you want to hang out
with Bert Kreischer
but what are the chances of that right
off the [__] bat until you earn a
name or somebody talks about you because
remember you got to be what's that old
expression you got to be uh notice
before you could be seen I don't [__]
know what it is but there's steps to
this thing don't get [__] down on
yourself at all they might not want to
talk to you now but guess what [__] if
you do the work they're going to want to
talk to you in 10 years and that's all
you [__] need to know and how do I
know that cause I'm [__] living it I
couldn't get arrested for a voiceover
but guess what happened my friends
started doing
shows the most notable one was Duncan
trostle Duncan Trussell put me on
[__] six of those episodes so all of
a sudden they let my agent know holy
[__] this [__] guy's voice so now
they get me more stuff for voiceover
work but it took time guys so don't sit
there cursing everybody
because your career isn't going as fast
as you wanted to go put the time in slow
it down a little bit think about you
what you're doing write it out
and man this it's not a [__] it's not
a race it's a [__] Marathon
it's all the [__] advice they give
you is a stand-up comic that you're
funny stick with it believe in yourself
and this is for anybody we discuss how
it would be with a band right what would
it be for a band three Toys four toys
you want a headline but now
[__] uh
uh who called you
Alice in Chains called you and they want
you to go on 20 like [__] we want to do
our own headlining tour but now Allison
Chains call me but you know what that
tour with Allison Chains is going to
teach you something else
it's going to add something else to your
[__] resume
you know when I work with bird or Joe or
when I used to open for Paul Rodriguez
any of those guys I always learned a
little something but that's not what
we're talking about here what we're
talking about is waiting for you to turn
on the [__] food chain
wait for it you're not you have to get
into that food chain and then move up
you know like the cons you ever watch
those shows oh oh and they hit Hammers
and then it moves down and you hit the
conveyor belt
let's just get on the conveyor belt and
then every like 10 notches
it's like uh when you go to Vegas and
bet black or whatever it falls on either
one if you don't but every 10 notches
you'll fall into the notch
headline this that it's gonna happen but
don't want it too soon just because
you're doing comedy for three years and
you did 30 minutes the other night at
the local bar and a bunch of drunks gave
you a standing ovation don't mean you're
ready for dick guys it takes a lot more
than that it takes time so always
remember it's not a [__] race to the
Finish it's a [__] journey and you
don't know you just don't know like
right now I don't know but I'm having
[__] fun I'm looking forward to my
next date in New York I'm looking
forward to Philadelphia I'm looking
forward for this pilot I'm gonna shoot
because I slowed it down a little bit
and I'm more [__] enthusiastic than
[__] epicot suckers and it's Monday
the 26th of [__] September we're
already dog I still remember getting
covered in [__] December still
remember [__] I can't believe this
[__] year has flown and because this
year's plan listen Cox up it's time
don't wait for nobody
it's [__] taken that war is still on
and you're still [__] thinking about
your next career move Tip Top Magoo
[__] this is the final quarter and
now it becomes a [__] race to see how
you can close out this year to set you
up for 2023 and that's it and that's
that [__] suck it's going to be a
[__] great week
Monday Night Football tonight and that's
it I love you [__] I'll be back
Wednesday the 28th and we'll chit chat
some more [__] take my advice to heart
if you're thinking about getting married
give it a shot what do you got to
[__] lose
just don't have no kids so the divorce
is easy you take the iron she takes the
Subaru you know what I'm saying I love
your [__] suckers and now for a word for
my [__] sponsors Jack
all right you bad [__] thank
you for having my back today
it was fun it was fun doing the podcast
today but [__] fun the joint is brought
to you by expressvpn Listen People are
watching you you want to go out into the
dark web and see why the other side
lives you know your Uncle Joey only
recommends brands that I believe in and
that's why when I say expressvpn is the
best it's the [__] bet expressvpn
doesn't allow your activity online lots
of free vpns make money by selling your
data not expressvpn expressvpn is always
blazing fast and lets me stream videos
in HD that's why CNET Business Insider
and the [__] birds all rate
expressvpn the number one VPN in the
world I use expressvpn whenever I'm in a
hotel I love expressvpn because it gives
you peace of mind knowing that my data
is secure right now go to expressvpn.com
Joey and I'm going to get you an extra
three months and a one year package
that's
expressvpn.com
Joey the joint is also brought to you by
DraftKings listen DraftKings is on fire
right now you bet five dollars on any
football team you get 200 free bets and
what you do is that's your bankroll you
take that money you bet Prof bets you
you can bet side bets who scores first
and that's where the money is at
on DraftKings you also has the same game
polish the more legs you bet the more
cash you win do me a favor download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app right now use
promo code Joey and get 203 bets if your
team wins you place five dollars on a
football team football ain't you we got
the baseball playoffs coming up
[__] and these are going to be
smoking this year so again that's go
Joey when you download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app or you download the
DraftKings fantasy at DraftKings
Sportsbook is the official sports
betting partner of the NFL minimum age
and eligibility restrictions apply see
show notes for details now go to
DraftKings right now download it and
let's win some [__] money to
join us also you brought to you by
freeze pipe how much do I like freeze
pipe listen I just busted out the 2023
bubbler oh my [__] god it's beautiful
you freeze the little wing of it when
you're ready to [__] see the devil
you
pull it out of the freezer you pack that
[__] up and you hit it like a
Savage that you are yum yum Eat Em Up
The Hot Smoke passes through the Frozen
bark down cooling down the smoke as you
inhale I love I love that products I
take it outside I see the [__] devil
quickly freeze pipe is non-toxic and it
freezes faster than water and stays
Frozen longer freeze pipe cools down the
Smoke by hundreds of degrees
now freeze pipe is even better because
they've updated their bong so you have
six independent freezing call which
means the [__] air is like [__]
warm Buddha air you know what I'm saying
it's like it's like uh what's those
people bullish there they're nice your
Uncle Joe is taking care you go to the
freeze pipe.com pressing code Joey and
save 10 on your first order you're gonna
love it get yourself a new bong a pipe
or a bubbler that's the freeze pipe.com
pressing code Joey to save 10 percent
I want to thank DraftKings freeze pipe
joint VPN Express and new savages for
having my back I'll see you Wednesday
Tip Top Magoo